welcome back to another ochetto tv
episode of double ko compilation
double chin
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
true
[Music]
[Music]
sure
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
hi
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa whoa
[Music]
look
[Music]
true
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
want to be featured in ochoto tv send in
your clips by following these steps
before you submit your clips make sure
the quality of the video is clear
put your ign as a file name for your
video
limit submissions to three to five clips
a week per category
don't spam submissions and don't send
folders with your clips on it
avoid full-length matches or just cut
the clip you want on the desired play
until the end of the round
next send your clips via dropbox in the
correct category
you can always find it on the
description of every other tv series
once you upload your video file if it
prompts you to give your name
just put in your igm
also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay match
[Music]
please understand that it may take some
time for some clips to be featured
because of the review process
thanks for watching don't forget to hit
like and be sure to subscribe for more
tekken content
[Music]
you